la société aristophil a été créé par
gérard lhéritier un collectionneur
reconnu passionné d'histoire
elle proposait aux épargnants d'investir
dans des lettres et manuscrits de
personnages historiques comme victor
hugo mozart jean cocteau ou encore
napoléon des placements financiers qu'il
était censé rapporter près de 8%
d'epargne des courtiers et des
gestionnaires de patrimoine proposent à
leurs clients ces investissements une
plus value juteuse qui a attiré 18 mille
particulier à travers la france mais en
fait la belle histoire cash est une
arnaque
les oeuvres vendues aurait été
surévalués par des experts qui aurait
été de connivence avec gérard lhéritier
c'est à dire que les investisseurs les
payer jusqu'à parfois trois fois leur
valeur réelle et gérard lhéritier aurait
mis en place un montage financier bien
connue des escrocs on appelle ça la
pyramide de ponzi
les nouveaux investisseurs paient en
fait les bénéfices des premiers jusqu'à
l'implosion du système lempire de papier
reposerait donc sur des comptes tronqué
la société finit par faire faillite
les comptes sont bloqués les épargnants
perdent leurs placements et selon les
dernières estimations ce sont près d'un
milliard d'euros qui aurait été perdu un
véritable scandale dans le milieu de
l'art
françoise est l'une de ces investisseurs
aujourd'hui elle doit faire face à
d'importants problèmes financiers elle a
perdu 80 mille euros en investissant
dans un lot de manuscrits mozart et les
grands compositeurs
à l'époque elle y croyait dur comme fer
et était même très fier de savoir que
ces oeuvres étaient exposées au grand
public
voilà c'est là que je venais vous 21
car la société possède et même un musée
celui des lettres et des manuscrits
donc il y avait les jardins sur le côté
donc tout le rez de chaussée
c'était nos musées
c'était très sombre à l'intérieur pour
protéger les documents et là ça donnait
sur le petit jardin qui va le rouleau de
salle il était là pour être chaussées
avec un tas de documents le concernant
on s'était très bien présente et se voit
que ça mettait en confiance en 2015
laventure s'arrête et le musée fermé ses
portes
françoise n'a jamais pu y retourner
las une ancienne d'aristo si j'aurais
voulu voir le jardin est ce que c'est
possible
c'est pas possible pourtant c'était des
bons souvenirs alors à l'époque c'était
un bon souvenir
françoise est amer elle estime que
gérard lhéritier l'ancien patron
d'aristo fils l'a en partie financée
grâce à son investissement
oui oui c'est certainement avec notre
argent qu'il a fait ce musée est
automatiquement puisque ce n'était quand
même pas mal à investir
donc c'était relativement facile pour
lui cet homme mis en examen pour
escroquerie en bande organisée
nous avons tenté à plusieurs reprises de
le contacter via son avocat et son
conseiller en communication
ils n'ont pas souhaité s'exprimer sur
cette affaire en cours l'histoire de
françoise c'est celle de 18 mille petits
épargnants qui croyaient en la bonne
affaire en 2011
cette retraitée de l'administration
cherche à placer l'argent récupéré suite
à la vente d'une maison afin de le faire
fructifier son courtier lui conseille
d'investir 80 mille euros dans l'un des
trésors de notre patrimoine
un chef-d'oeuvre de la musique
voilà une partition de mozart première
édition de la flûte enchantée mozart
c'est très bien mon père était un grand
musicien et les premiers prix de
conservatoire donc voilà ça m'a pas
dérangé une fois noir parce que c'était
intéressant et elle craque devant ce
placement séduisant j'ai investi avec ma
famille 80000 euros ya maintenant six
ans pour l'instant j'ai tout perdu
oui et c'est très gênant parce que j'en
ai besoin
à l'époque son courtier a de bons
arguments pour convaincre l'épargnante
il eu vent une offre alléchante où les
plus values défient toute concurrence
le courtier que je connais c'est une
d'imagés un placement qui rapporte un
peu plus que l'assurance vie c'était
7,75
enfin un mot un peu moins de 8% et donc
j'ai signé en décembre 2011
j'ai reçu ce beau document en janvier
2012 qui concernait la division avec ce
placement à 8%
françoise espérer gagner en cinq ans 40
% de plus-value
environ trente deux mille euros qui
seraient venus s'ajouter aux 80 milles
existants
au final il n'y a rien du tout est ce
que ça va faire - non j'aurais dû
toucher mon capital frustré cette
retraitée n'a jamais touché la somme
promise ni récupérer son investissement
initial
aujourd'hui elle fait face à des
difficultés financières
c'est pas normal de se faire spolier
comme ça alors qu'on a travaillé toute
sa vie on doit pouvoir récupérer au
moins un capital ce que je voudrais
c'est que cet argent on a pour vivre
tous les mois j'ai besoin de compléter
ma petite retraite
il me reste 1000 euros par mois pour
vivre est certainement quelque chose à
faire parce que c'est pas normal ça
existe c'est sur des documents qui
existe réellement
ce n'est pas du vent logiquement en
effet les 130 mille manuscrits existe
bel et bien mais pour le moment ils ont
été saisis par la justice
ils seront ensuite revendus aux enchères
les bénéfices réalisés permettront
d'indemniser en partie des victimes
mais comme il était surévalué pas sûr
qu'un jour françoise revoit sa 80000
euros